all right let's hear another call that
came in on work Casey oceans 10
Philadelphia
got a quick question okay to deal with a
all-you-can-eat Rain Man going to the
bar every day me and my lady and I
wasn't sure if we should order one or
you can eat we just if we were allowed
to share them or is that a violation we
go you're kicked out if we have so we
order two and we didn't eat enough but I
wanted more to go and I'm react to that
look dude here's the thing if you got
that you know that Bonnie and Clyde type
lady you know if you got that little
daredevil bad [__] and she don't mind
you know getting that one you know
$21.99 and one you know she got to sit
there and pretend like she and having
any wings
even if she having them I used to love
that [__] there when you would split
something some one person we're getting
you just sit behind you don't think the
[__] boss knew oh you're the weird
dude who just sits in a restaurant with
somebody and doesn't eat but also has
food and crumbs all over their shirt
you're busted man I remember our mom
would take us to this pizza place they
had a buffet and they had all you could
get fresh olives on there they had
probably that like an olive bar had
three types of olives which was a lot I
mean this was in late 90s that was a lot
of olives you know and we would get one
plate and all walk and hold it at the
same time like that [__] matter dude
for kids holding one plate like it's
like a Olympic torch trying to pretend
like since we all had our hand on it
that we got the the deal that it was all
you could eat nothing shadier than that
boy that's growing ivory all right there
you hide man eating real fast you like
uh you're like the James Bond of
digestion
you know you Lou you wait real quick and
and look at you know as soon as a
manager looks away or a phone call comes
in you [__] you know you to you tooth
down a couple of hits or something gang
so I look man I think if you're gonna
take it here's the thing if you take a
lady to a wing place first of all
i-it's kind of shady brah take your lady
to a nicer place where they got a little
bit of fish I'm saying buy that big
Ifans dinner buy your lady a fish dinner
cuz some ladies want a fist and what
that cart they want that jaw full of
carp you know they want a few no they
want to fall asleep at night and have a
little bit of mercury in the back of her
tongue women like precious metals so
don't get don't take your lady you know
for a damn couple of hot chicken wings
she's had two of them now her eyes are
watering her makeups running she looks
like a raccoon that got into a fight and
it was just starting to rain come on man
take your lady by her that fish dinner
by a bi yeah as you dinner you know I'm
saying carp [__] scallop mollusk sea
mollusk ahi ahi get your lady what she
deserves dude something that used to
swim and be free yacht they're buying
that [__] a small a swing with some
[__] mustard on it Kim and treat her
right give you by your lady something
had a hook in it because women like that
fish dinner
women like precious metals you know they
want jewelry gold diamonds or you know
shined up or coppers you know at least
it with fish dinner woman falls asleep
at night a little bit of mercury in her
and on her tongue a little bit of that
Merc Merc taste in her mouth make sure
at least feel some time in her
subconscious like somebody bought our
piece of jewelry so keep your lady off
the wings and buy Tamia JPS dinner thank
you guys for checking out this clip and
if you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz it's alarming